all right guys
bang bang i've got mark here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
yeah thanks paul for having me i'm
stoked to be here for sure let's jump
right into
your background kind of what did you do
before you started harvested financial
yeah so my whole background has been in
the options business you know i walked
out of college
i was actually an internship on the
college floor that like i saw what that
exchange floor looked like and
it was like you know paradise right the
energy that was going on there
the way guys were trading the way guys
were making money like just the
enthusiasm for that
product and like the energy of that
floor from 9 30 to 4 i was like i have
to be down there so
it was the pits that really lured me
into options originally
um and then you know as the business
transition the business started to
become more electronic the pits became
less interesting
i moved on to the more electronic side
of the business looking at how we could
capture opportunity across
the different exchanges and as options
kind of became more and more popular you
saw more and more exchanges growing up
so as a as a market maker our goal was
to
touch as much flow as we can and sitting
as a market maker at the center of the
business
you see exactly what goes on you have to
price the options you have to know how
they trade you have to know where
they're going to trade
you really have to know all the ins and
outs of how options work
and it was just a fascinating boot camp
to understand the industry
yeah for sure and so this whole idea of
options trading i think when most people
think of
trading they think of spot exchanges
right hey i buy and i sell an asset a
stock whatever it is
uh options is a little bit different so
maybe let's just start with like a
options 101 course like what exactly is
an option and how do people trade them
definitely so i think people are used to
buying stocks people are used to saying
you know what
apple's going up i'm going to buy apple
bitcoins going up i buy bitcoin if i buy
it at 10 000 it goes to 12 000 i've made
my 2 000
options are a whole different other
dimension right you have
this uh derivative relationship to the
underlying
and they have a sense of time too so
that's also a really important element
that options
when you buy a stock you hold the piece
of that company for as long as it's in
business
same with a crypto investment you're
holding that for as long as you want
with the option you get all these weird
behaviors because they expire because
they have a duration to that
and what you're looking for you know a
simple example would be a call option
that you have the right to buy that
stock or that underlying at a given
price
to be clear there are options on all
different kinds of things you can have
options on crypto
you can have commodities you can have
options on stocks we focus on equity
options
but an option can exist on any
underlying security
so buy a call option means you have the
right to buy that stock
at that fixed level well if stock goes
to that level
you then are sitting on a sort of convex
return
that you can use a small amount of
capital and really leverage your
position in that stock
if you think apple's gonna pop a great
way to make that play
would be to use an option strategy so if
it doesn't work out you have defined
risk it's going to expire it's going to
go to zero
which is different than an equity your
your apple equity might never go to zero
but
the options are going to go to zero
because they have that time frame and
they
make for some really interesting ways to
overlay on top of
existing strategies you know you might
be a long-term holder in any given
security and so options can complement
that portfolio but then they can act
totally different
they can act as ways to earn income on
the market they can act as ways to
you know balance and protect your
portfolio to the extent that you want to
secure it against a drawdown so
really options can provide almost any
type of feature and complement your
portfolio
that you're looking to do so let's start
with call options first and if i want to
uh
purchase a call option uh in apple let's
say walk me through kind of how that
works
okay so right now apple's trading around
120
i don't know exactly where we are right
now but around 120
so if i want to go out and buy one share
of apple i have to put out you know 120
if i want to buy say the 125 strike call
that would mean that i have the right to
buy apple stock
at 125 now with apple trading at 120
that you know that right isn't worth
anything except for its future
probability
of apple being over that amount so if i
have something that's expiring
next week or next month what's the
probability that apple's going to jump
over that level
by the expiration period and the big
question there is the volatility i think
a lot of people hear options and they
also hear volatility
so thinking about that call strike how
much do i think apple's going to move
is going to determine how much that
strike price that call
at that strike price is going to be
worth got it and then what about a put
option
so put option lets you gives you the
right to sell the stock
and so it's betting on the opposite
direction
that you know you can use that as a
protection policy it's a great insurance
policy that you know
if apple's trading at 120 you get
nervous with it dropping below 110 you
want to protect your investment you buy
a put at 110. so that gives you the
right to sell apple 110
you'll no matter where apple trades
between now and the expiration of that
contract you'll be able to sell apple
stock for 110.
so it gives you the right to sell with a
put option and the right to buy with a
call option
got it and then talk about the premium
right so in either of those scenarios
how can i earn premium
for sure so premium gets back to that
volatility concept
that the option has both an intrinsic
value and it's got an extrinsic value
and that intrinsic value is if apple's
trading at 120
and the call is struck at 115 well you
know that's worth at least five dollars
because i can buy the stock for 115 and
sell it immediately for 120.
but how much more is that worth well
that's
what traders options traders are betting
on every day and trying to price
how much is apple going to move how much
is bitcoin going to move
well if it's going to move a lot if you
have a name that's you know a tesla or a
shopify or something like that that's
whipping around
there's gonna be a lot of that premium
in there there's gonna be a lot of that
volatility extrinsic value
and so that premium is both your
potential as the owner of the option
that you know apple's going i'm betting
on it going over 125
but it's also the value that the seller
of that option can capture
so we talked about buying calls as a way
to buy stock
and buying puts as a way to sell stock
but you can sell calls and you can sell
puts
so if you sell an option you're going to
be the one that's collecting that
premium
and in a way you're betting against
something not happening
and so that's another dimension of
options that gets really interesting is
that you can train them from both the
buy
side and the sell side it lets you be
the insurance writer
so when you write an option you're the
person saying you know what
i think the probability of house fires
in this area is
90 if i sell 10 people
insurance at 100 and i only have to pay
out 90
on average that 10 difference that i've
made on average
that's your options premium and that's
the value that you as a
writer of options gets to keep and you
as an owner well you're hoping for moves
you're hoping for that gas behind it to
go
absolutely and it feels like what a lot
of people are doing
is they're basically already in the
market so you talked about kind of using
the securities that you already own
to participate explain how that works
for sure i think there are two broad
categories of the way you can approach
an option strategy
so they're great at being an overlay on
an existing portfolio that you have so
do you want to amplify that do you want
to like turn up the gas on your existing
holdings
do you want to protect your existing
holdings that's a great way to
dampen the overall volatility whether
you're reaching retirement whether
you're reaching a savings goal
like you might want to lock in a little
bit more of that money and you know
there is a trade-off there you know you
pay for insurance that's gonna be a
little bit of a drag on returns
ultimately
but that can be a very beneficial way to
sort of dampen the exposure that you
might get with the
you know equity investments that you
currently have they also work well
separately though and they can be traded
entirely separately as an opportunity
capture and diversification element
in your portfolio taking advantage of a
lot of those things like writing premium
using defined risk strategies to collect
that premium
and benefit from being the writer of
insurance
yeah what's so interesting to me is a
lot of the options one people don't
understand it but two is
you're essentially making a bet with
somebody else
that a thing is going to happen in a
predefined amount of time right so
you think that this thing you know a is
going to happen in the next 90 days
i think it's not going to happen and
therefore we enter into basically a bet
there's nuance to it that's an over
generalization but like that's basically
what's making the market
right is that you and i have a
disagreement as to what's gonna happen
in the future and we're both willing to
wager
risk for a reward in uh in kind of
wagering on what we think the future
looks like right
exactly i think that's a great way to
frame it that this is a risk transfer
that there's no free lunches out there
right i'd be completely wrong to tell
people that options are the secret
and that you know there's a free pot of
money at the end of this rainbow
they're just a risk transfer exactly
like you say and i think what makes it
really interesting
uh from a market perspective is that
unlike equities
when you're buying or selling equities
or when you're buying and selling most
other
underlying assets you're probably
dealing with naturals
whereas in the options market you have a
lot of these intermediaries
that are pricing all of the different
strikes and
stocks that have options listed you know
there are a million different option
series out there
there's not always natural liquidity in
every single one of those
so you have this other important
component in the market of these market
makers that are sitting there
standing ready to deal at any given
point they're the bookie that's moving
the line on the jets versus giants game
yeah absolutely now this stuff's super
complex uh you started a company
to uh fix that explain a little bit
about
uh where did the idea for harvested
financial come from
for sure so you know spending all those
years as a market maker you really
develop a passion for what the inside
nitty-gritty works
and i find myself talking to people and
they go well that's kind of cool but
like
wha what's the detail here like how can
i make this work for me
and so what harvested financial is is
we're an advisory business
and so we're specifically set up as an
advisor
and not a broker because we want to take
the pain away from people of managing
those options strategies
i very much found myself trying to
execute my own strategies for my
personal account
and you're chained to the computer
you've got to be there at four o'clock
when those
you know option contracts expire you've
got to be there picking your strike and
you've got to be managing this trade
on a very detailed basis so what
harvested does is as an advisor
we take all of that away and we're
digital advisors so we've automated it
so we have an entire platform that goes
from recommendation
all the way down to execution of that
strategy
and computers are really good at moving
all those levers in and out and so
by automating this digital process like
we've developed a platform that makes
options super accessible and
you know easy for people to integrate
into their portfolios
absolutely and part of this it feels
like is this like robo advisor
for uh options trading uh how much of
what you guys are doing is
educating people on how options work and
why they should have
as part of their portfolio versus just
simply helping people execute the actual
uh trading of options you know it's a
really interesting combination of both
um you know there are certainly people
that are coming to us
because they're saying that hey i just
want exposure to options and i
understand that they provide
these big buckets and for that we've
really designed these model portfolios
that we can have
and so you can simply say i want the
diversification of options
and we take care of the rest it's
similar to like a target date fund or
something like that
so there's certainly that type of client
that just wants access to that
and they want to understand you know a
little bit of where that's coming from
you know get into some of the basics of
how decay works and
you know what is a put and what is a
call what does premium mean all those
sort of things that we talked about
there's definitely a distinct segment
that are interested in that
but we also work with people that know
what they want to do and they just don't
want to deal with the pain of managing
it
and so that would have been me you know
if this company didn't exist two years
ago or
i'm sorry if this company had existed
two years ago i would have signed up
with them and said you know what
i want this call selling put selling you
know premium capture strategy
can you just go and do it so we work
with people that have these ideas
and just need them implemented on a sort
of regular serial basis
got it and how did you guys actually
come up with uh what securities
uh to trade from an option standpoint
how do you set
strike prices like explain to me a
little bit about what's the nuts and
bolts behind the actual product
for sure so we've got a lot of our
strategies backed by data and kind of
the first project when we set out to
you know form harvested was running a
whole bunch of numbers on these
different strategies
and thinking about what kind of not
necessarily to back test them in terms
of an optimization standpoint
like we're not here to say that if you
sell exactly this strike that's the
perfect level to trade at
it's more about describing the texture
of returns that those are going to give
so what does adding a short premium
strategy look like in your portfolio
how does that perform when the market's
rising you know you can't get everything
right
uh so like you can have strategies that
do well when the market rises when the
market
you know is neutral and when the market
falls and you sort of like what's the
right combination
of income that i can earn when the
market's not moving that i can use to
reallocate and rebalance and so we did a
lot of work analyzing the data behind
what the texture of those returns looks
like and so we use that to help inform
how to spread people out amongst the
different strategies
so that's really what drove our sort of
model portfolio selection
but really for those really active
investors there are certainly people
that know what they want
and you know they sometimes will ask us
for data about how this is going to look
and how that's going to integrate with
the rest of their portfolio
other times they just know their
strategy and just want it banged out
yeah that's awesome and talk to me about
the product itself in terms of what the
user experience is like
so our goal is to be as simple as
possible and
you know really try and figure out how
much the client wants to get involved
with their strategies and
so that's where a model portfolio works
very well for people that say
i need a little bit of different i want
something a little bit different in my
portfolio
you know bonds are dead right like we're
hearing that from a lot of clients that
they go
you know someone told me that i should
put 40 percent of my money in bonds
because that's what the 60 40 allocation
says
and i'm earning you know .000 on it
so what where can i get something
different so like for that type of
client that they definitely can go in
and say
give me the diversify or give me you
know some income
it's that simple that the goal is that
we do all the nitty gritty of the strike
selection
and the rolling and you know for the
most part we're finding people aren't
particularly interested in that
um so simple intuitive
and education is really a big front for
us you know we have a director of
education whose mission is
to help our clients understand how their
strategies are working
what the performance metrics look like
you know what strategies to select
in the beginning and creating an
interface that allows all this to happen
seamlessly
yeah and talk a little bit i guess in
terms of uh
when you guys look at the macro
environment and all the volatility
that's happened in the market in 2020
is that a tailwind for options trading
is that a a headwind
how do you think of that i think it's
definitely been a tailwind for options
trading you know i look at what the occ
uh the options clearing corporation that
tracks all the listed options trades
their numbers have just been booming
over the last year and i think that's a
great thing
right i think you know there's sometimes
uh these conversations going around that
oh retail investors are
you know buying calls and it's flipping
the market around and
you know the you know traders that are
going on these yolo bets and look how
dangerous this is
you know there are certainly very
dangerous things you can do with options
but i think overall it's great that
people are getting involved and getting
their hands dirty because
you know when you get into any risk
class the only way to understand that is
to really roll up your sleeves
and feel the pain of losing you know
whether it's traders i've worked with or
books i've read on traders
everyone talks about getting burned and
developing a risk management system
that's going to help you kind of move on
so i think this overall interest in
options
has been fantastic and whether that's
volatility driven
or you know whether that's just general
positivity
volatility really makes options
interesting and it's where they shine
to either capture opportunity right
stocks start moving a lot like you can
put on some very odds on risk managed
spreads
or you can use it to buffer right there
are plenty of people that go
you know what like looking at the market
going into the election
how do i protect myself there um so
volatility
is uh you know that's really the main
pricing factor in options
so the more that moves you know the more
excited we get
absolutely and talk a little bit about
just how much
leverage people can use in options
yeah so uh options because they you know
are derivative of the stock you know
instead of having to buy that 120
apple share you can actually buy a call
for a dollar
two dollars and so i think you can get a
lot of leverage
but the way we like to think about it is
using that capitally efficient
so instead of saying oh i can 10x my
money
that you want to think about it as a way
to
capitalize on odds on returns so one of
our
strategies that might uh kind of
highlight this is we call it the rolling
ball strategy
so imagine you have a bullish thesis on
an underlying investment your option is
to buy that investment
or what we do with the rolling bull is
we roll a series of call spreads over
time
so if you think on average this stock is
going to go up
more than 50 of the time we'll lay out a
bunch of trades that give me 50
odds of that going up and if you have
some edge that's gonna
suggest that 55 60 of the time
tesla apple whatever your name is goes
up
trading that series of call spreads is
gonna be much more efficient for your
returns
something like two to three x your
returns compared to you know
seeing 20 and 30 rises in the stock so
that's where we really see the
efficiency of leverage
but done in a very risk-managed way
right you don't want to necessarily
lean into something with you know highly
leveraged play
you want to have a series of plays that
are you know defined
lost defined gains capture the games
when they pop don't have to worry about
when to sell
but cover me on the downside so you know
i'm not screaming at red numbers or
seeing red numbers scream at me in the
face
um so leveraged well managed i think is
the important key there
got it and when people hear options
obviously there's this very bullish case
right you guys have built a great
platform in terms of helping them do
that
how should people think about the risk
right so there's risk management but
like what is the risk in options trading
there's a lot of risks in options
trading and you know interestingly
one of the risks is not even necessarily
what people might think in terms of
dollar loss or whatnot but the
operational risk of options is actually
very real
so one of the strategies that we use is
a butterfly strategy
um you know some listeners might be
familiar with that but generally the
idea is to
um bet on the market not moving so
this strategy pays out if stock sits
right here
where we are today and the sort of
options premium collapses
the way to achieve that though is
through four different contracts
across three different strikes and so
when it comes time to close that
depending on where stock is
you're really looking it's 350 351 where
are we going to close are we going to be
above or below that
that that kind of risk is actually far
more dangerous to people
than excess leverage that you know
managing the ins and outs of that
you know if you're not there and you get
distracted for 10 minutes all of a
sudden you're buying 100 shares of stock
that you didn't expect to or selling 100
shares of stock that you didn't expect
to
so i think operational risk is one of
those sneaky risks that you know
underlies
you know options trading and that's what
we really want to solve that's what a
computer platform does incredibly well
um and tightening up that whole process
there yeah and talk a little bit just
about in terms of that operational
efficiency um
the team that you've built so far kind
of how has that come together
and then we could talk a little bit
about kind of in the future where you
guys are
are aiming to be absolutely so you know
right now we're a relatively small team
it's uh
five of us total uh three engineers uh
and a director of education like i
mentioned plus myself
um so really what we're trying to do is
build the simplest tightest platform to
handle all of
the the advisory process so you know it
really starts at
uh onboarding a client and understanding
what is going to work for them
and you know there's very much that
educational you know uh
assignment uh process where we try and
like assign the person to the right
strategy and figure out where they fit
you know what's your target date uh for
retirement objective or whatnot so
that's a process that we've streamlined
and automated there but then also on the
execution side
you know making sure our orders are
going out efficiently um
i actually still do a little bit of
semi-automation because the trader in me
can't not have my hands
and fingerprints on those orders um and
i still think there's quite a bit of
edge
and that's actually a big place that we
deliver edge as an advisor
that the options market structure not
only are there the operational risks
but one of the improvements we can bring
is execution
quality so you know stock markets are
relatively tight
if you want to buy apple the bid is a
penny below where the offer
is in apple with options markets it's
not always that tight and we like to go
with the more liquid strategies
or more liquid securities generally but
it's not always the case
and for every time we get a penny better
for our client that's an extra dollar in
their pocket
so you know instead of paying 160 that
might be offered we try to look at the
155
160 can i get a little bit can i look at
what the
market's doing is you know volatility
coming in do i want to be a little bit
more passive so
there there's a lot of automation going
on in the background but for really that
precision trading we still rely on like
a little bit of that special human touch
um so i think our goal for the future
is to build more scale to build more
automation
that is going to allow us to serve more
clients and serve you know
the more people we have executing
strategies the better pricing we can get
overall in the market
so we have the ability to start looking
at block trades we have the ability to
start looking at
different styles of trading um once you
know the automation lends itself to
scale yeah that's awesome
so what do you hope to build here right
or what kind of what what's the
goal or mission in terms of if you look
out 10 years from now
and and you've accomplished that you say
this was success
what does that look like for you as a
business um
uh today so our mission is that
derivatives are for everyone
and that we believe that everyone has
some need for
some of the elements that derivatives
provide and so we like to bucket them
into diversify
amplify and protect and so
most everyone has a need for some type
of derivative strategy
some type of alternative allocation in
their portfolio we'd really like to see
as common as people are investing in
their 401ks and they're putting money in
passive low fee investments
which i still think are great i still
think that should be a majority of where
people are
putting their money but having that
alternative class there
that people are starting to have that 5
10 15
allocation to a passive income stream to
a protection source
having that type of strategy more
broadly accessible to people
i think that looks like a huge success
yeah that's awesome
and and i feel like as you guys are
building this out too uh
not only one is there the education
piece of hey here's what options are
here's how they can
um help your existing portfolio here's
some risk that you can take
here's that passive income but also the
technology you're building i'm assuming
will eventually kind of
spread out across both other asset
classes so not just kind of
public securities but into other things
and then also you can add
all types of derivatives on top of that
right absolutely like equities is really
just a start
i think there are some really
interesting things you can look at in
crypto markets i think there are really
interesting things you can look at in a
lot of the commodities markets
um you know one of our big uh kind of
white whales that we look at is
structured products and that's an
enormous market out there right
but one of the problems with structured
markets or structured product markets
is that they're single counter parties
so you enter into a structured product
agreement
and you have a single counterparty
you're facing off as the occ
the options clearing corporation is a
centrally cleared
entity that there's never been a default
there's never been any concern about
what the cds of this bank is trading at
that you might enter into a bilateral
trade but it's completely cross
guaranteed
and so not only do you have the
counterparty risk with structured
products but you also have
the cost right like if you're looking at
like two percent on some of these things
we're charging 50 basis points and like
we're charging 50 basis points on liquid
markets you can easily get in and out of
and so starting to
look at some of those packages that
people are interested in for their
simplicity
and attacking that as a way to get
people more liquid
more efficient cost-effective you know
investment solutions
yeah it makes uh makes complete sense
where can people find you on the
internet and find harvested financial
yes you should check us out at
harvestedfinancial.com and
if you throw our promo code pomp at the
end of that harvested financial dot com
pomp we're offering our beta rate uh for
the first three months that anyone signs
up
so our beta rate is only five bucks a
month um and
that's half of our current rate so 10
bucks a month is the minimum fee
and that gets you access to an entire
suite of options products um that'll get
you up to 25 grand
of option strategies managed for only 10
bucks a month and that provides a really
nice diversification for
people's portfolios as small as 500 is
our minimum
so you can find us at harvested
financial dot com you can check out our
twitter
harvested underscore d-a-f-e derivatives
are for everyone
uh and that's where we're at awesome man
uh before uh we finish up i asked the
same two questions to everybody and
you'll get to ask me one uh to end it
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
oh i think reminiscences of a stock
operator
um the edwin lefebvre book um the
one of my first internships was at a
hedge fund at uh tutor investments with
paul der jones and uh
i remember hearing about his interest in
that book so you know early getting into
the markets uh
reading that and thinking about you know
being that bucket shop operator and uh
you know trading in the swings and the
highs and the lows of it all so i think
going through that personally too
afterwards that that still definitely
resonates as an interesting book that's
great what was it like working at a
tutor
it was interesting so i was only there
for a summer you know i was a college
intern
but i absolutely remember paul walking
in one day um and just
you know having come back from safari
and like you know just regaling us with
these like fantastic stories
and all i could think was wow how can i
get in those shoes
like i i want to be him i want to be
sitting right there
that's awesome story that is a fantastic
story
uh uh the second question is a little
bit more fun which is uh
aliens believer or non-believer
uh i'm probably a non-believer um
why yeah i think i'm a non-believer but
i
i think that's probably because i
haven't seen you know distinct enough
evidence right uh
but that said i i remember actually
listening to a great podcast with
um uh dan aykroyd um who is a huge alien
believer
and after two hours of listening to him
talk about it
i think i came a little bit off my high
horse so i'm willing to be convinced of
anything
but as of now probably i would have to
say no
my whole thing is just the universe is
so big it's gotta have
they got to be out there somewhere okay
so that's i as a probability guy with
options right like i should be thinking
like it in those terms that you know
like you said the universe is so big
what are the odds that we're the only
group of uh
you know knuckleheads on this spacecraft
absolutely
you could ask me one question to finish
up what you got for me
uh if you were going to describe
yourself as an option strategy how would
you describe yourself
what what is the one that only only goes
up right stocks only go up is there an
option strategy that only goes up that's
me
long calls that works for me long calls
and and maybe out of the money calls
right you want that convexity
that like you want to buy something for
a dime and get paid ten dollars for it
i want as much asymmetry as possible in
uh
in my portfolio so uh if uh if that's
what does it then i'm down for sure
all right well option strategies might
very well be for you
awesome mark listen thank you so much
for doing this i'm super excited about
what you guys are doing
uh i think that uh options are obviously
a key part of many people's portfolios
but uh
just making it easier to understand
educating people on it and then
obviously having a platform
that can kind of you know drastically
reduce the barrier to entry
uh for folks is a pretty good idea so uh
thanks so much for
coming on we'll do this again in the
future absolutely thanks so much for
having me this is a blast